the decision to end the pregnancy during
the first three months belongs to the
woman and her doctor' not the government
thus the anti-abortion laws of 46 states
for rendered unconstitutional abortion
means a baby dies America wake up
America judgment from Almighty God is
coming
[Applause]
[Music]
pregnancy is temporary abortion is
forever
that's right abortion stops obedient
change your mind you know a regular day
at the only abortion clinic in
Mississippi some information it's a
daily battle to function as a permanent
rotation of anti-abortion activists
confront the women as they enter you
every child it's precious you don't have
to do this we can help you I don't see
anyone come out smiling
Dana Chisholm and Berkeley Austrians
say it's their duty to save babies your
child is precious your child would like
to live Dana what are you hoping for
from these women when you say that
oh I've I've helped a lot I've helped
them what are you hoping very actionable
I would love David they would they would
see they would come out and that has
happened they've come out crying and we
we help them little hands little feet
breaks your heart so you carry this
model of week like I do sometimes and
you know I think that's precipitated one
of the sites of the babies the women
look at this and this is a real baby to
them that's what I try to we both try to
make them realize this is a real baby
it's not just a blob of tissue it has a
beating heart it has fingers and toes
you know it's a real baby it's just not
ready to come out yet but it's still a
real baby it's still a person
up to 40 women come here every day
summer teenagers from the poorest parts
of the state others are working women
with families what they all have in
common is that none of them want to be
here shonda's baby at 12 weeks and six
days off-camera her eyes overflow with
tears this 19 year old is about to have
an abortion she says she has no choice
because she was raped 41 year old s
Tanika already has four children she
says she and her husband simply can't
afford another was one of our decisions
in my life - in the pregnancy and didn't
I just can't do it
I'm not in position to do it mentally
financially she says the scene that
greeted her outside was a shock they're
out there telling us that we're gonna go
- hey I think they have pictures of
fetuses and babies you know and I think
that is way more disturbing than
whatever they're trying to you feel
scared and I'm very uncomfortable just
disrespected more than anything
security was very very supportive
especially with the protestors outside
just you know reassuring you and
basically defending all the young ladies
they were getting out the car defending
you know their honor and their choice
I'm a clinic defender and you can call
me what you want but you're not coming
on this Drive where you
outside a team of escorts mainly
volunteers a tasked with stopping the
women being bombarded it's a job they
take very seriously and this is David a
cage Werner he's an activist social
justice activist and he's a defender and
I'm just me
Michele Cologne so Michele she's the
leader of modest but she's the leader of
although part of why why I could say I
come out here is I don't I would feel
like the biggest hypocrite in the world
telling a woman what to do with her body
yes it takes two to make a baby but at
the end of the day she's gonna carry the
baby you know she's gonna be the way
Society burdens her with a lot of the
things with with the childbirth and
everything so it's not my decision all
they want to do is sit out here and
judge them and tell them what terrible
people they are and ironically hide
behind their religion doing that you
know if you look in the Bible Jesus
would not be out here judging and
condemning these women for what they're
doing they don't know their personal
decisions though even they'll even say
we don't know your personal life but yet
we're gonna sit out here and make these
judgments on you and not to me is just
the height of absurdity or once you love
that child on the path of a church we
can help you love that baby
women exit the clinic behind this
blacked-out fence getting them in and
out is a very tricky operation they're
running a gauntlet it's the escorts aim
to get them through safely
it's these protesters aims to stop them
from having an abortion ma'am if there's
anything I can do to help please let us
help adoption is an option do you think
that maybe you're making it more
stressful for these women who are
already experiencing a really
challenging moment in their lives I
would prefer that I'd make it a little
bit more challenge if I was making a
very difficult decision an important
decision a life-changing decision maybe
they know that already you know
something I do know that I don't have to
tell them that in Mississippi a majority
probably 80% of the people in
Mississippi think abortion is wrong I
don't have to tell them that because
they already know but but some of them
maybe don't think about the baby as
being a boy or a girl
a son that could grow up to be a
carpenter or they do don't they they
probably having all sorts of terrible we
I thought that's about the thing that
they really have to do I want him to
think it through
and make the right choice how did you
know that not I don't but if you let me
talk to him III can make you know maybe
draw that conclusion that they've really
thought it through but they built a
barrier here that they don't they feel
like me offering adoption to them
is there anything telling them that the
adoption is an option that is free that
there's housing there's a place up and
locally here that for women that are
over 18 that they can stay for free
through the pregnancy because their
boyfriend says you have this baby I'm
kicking you out would that be that probe
or it's not going to tell them the place
in the clinic it's not going to tell
them that excuse me ma'am I'm praying
for you if there's anything we can do to
help please let us help god is so good
he can be our strength when we are weak
let's talk on the way out and once they
get inside
that's a competent period that we have
to go through just to sell them down so
that they can get through the process if
that's what they want to do do you have
any questions about the surgical
abortion that you want to choose okay
Betty Thompson is the chief counselor at
the clinic she says its survival has
constantly been under threat your job is
to use the breathing technique that
we're about to give you now since 1998
in this clinic open every year there is
three or four laws significant laws in
the legislature that are chipping away
at women's rights to have access and
they have no idea really what women
really need they get on this bandwagon
and they decide for women what they
should and should not do and that is
totally unfair so we have had it rough
trying to stay in compliance trying to
follow everything to the letter of the
law and we've been very successful at
doing that I had following the law
the last law
that has really that we sued about is
the one where the doctors had to have
admitting privileges at local area
hospitals I was very involved in that we
wrote all the hospitals in the area
asking for our physicians to be able to
admit patients and there was a there was
a difficulty or stumbling about at every
hospital and eventually they just said
flat out no why because I think that
they think that the public may not use
their hospital if they are so sated with
us cuz they'd be seen as endorse yes
they would see be seen as endorsing the
procedure the need that women half of
this health service is not going to go
away the clinic is struggling to stay
open
amid sweeping measures to restrict
abortion across the u.s. ultrasound
technician Stephanie battle says she
believes if they are shut down
women will resort to desperate measures
they will drain bleach certain time
anything that they think they will make
them have an abortion fire dancing steps
there's no matter kick on and probably
go back to the clothes hanger hotel but
it's just our roof back here to where
they that they will go to the shrink to
have this procedure done because make
summer here and I said if they need this
done they mean it by all meanings
in the past doctors have been threatened
it isn't always easy working here you
feel intimidated
no no they try and intimidate yes what
do they do they yell to me I shouldn't
right there
when I was pregnant he told me I should
take my baby and a clinic like that my
baby is gonna be evil stuff like that
and I'm like a Christian why are you
telling that my baby's gonna be evil
because I'm pregnant
and then working inside of this cleaning
like you're not gonna pay my bills so
you don't have no say-so to me I'm grown
just how you've grown you have your
thing I have man outside the standoff
continues therefore the wicket will not
stand in the judgment nor sinners in the
Assembly of the righteous for the Lord
knows the way of the righteous but the
way of the wicked will perish their
approaches couldn't be more different
they know that their baby that's ten
fingers and ten toes and a heartbeat of
brainwaves dear God I prayed that they
would turn to You Lord father I just
pray you bless them I know that women
come here for anxiety and fear and more
just other reasons I pray they would
Lord I pray you turn their heart to
their baby the escorts use loud music to
drown out the activists the clinic's
future now lies in the hands of the law
the team behind it insist they won't be
quiet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Amanda Walker Sky News Jackson
Mississippi
[Music]